I'm going to start by listing a few jobs
and I just want you to say yes or no as
to whether you've done them okay house
painter yes lifeguard yes dating
consultant yes ordained minister yes my
child one of my summer jobs was on
Catalina Island and I befriended a guy
named Reverend Bob he came to me one day
and said Brian I need you to perform a
wedding because I booked two weddings
same day same time different locations
and I show up it was at an airport and
I'm looking around and this guy says who
are you and I what I'm the minister
let's where are we going to do this he
said we're going to go into an airplane
once we get over the Hollywood Sign we
want to start the ceremony we get inside
I'm next to the pilot then the bride and
groom and the Witnesses in the back so I
have to scream so I'm in the back going
remember love one another
but don't stand at each other's shadows
together